I remember that when I was a kid that
the notion of military fitness being a
kind of a model but I think there's a
Canadian Australian you know guide was
all about jumping jacks and things like
that so we get that but we don't think
of the military's being a place for
psychological fitness and he started as
a urologist and then you pivoted to the
psychological component can you describe
a little bit of the psychology of a new
recruit you know did it take it take an
average an average recruit I know you
talked to hundreds of thousands of
thousands if not more of them what do
you say how do you teach a 17 18 I guess
where they build or the 18 19 year-old
to prepare themselves to turn an injury
into a growth experience well we don't
start there we start with you know how
to communicate better and how to make
better decisions and how to look at what
happens realistically instead of
catastrophic Lee and it can be as
something as simple as one thing every
recruit has to do is successfully before
they can graduate let's go through the
gas stream and in every class there's
some number of people who just are
paralyzed in activity and you and it
used to be before we had this kind of
training that the drill sergeant would
basically just scream at the guy until
he either peed in his pants and went
home or or went into the thing we have
learned a better technique that gets
more people through and which is so tell
us why you are afraid to go in and they
will list you know on I think I'm going
to die I won't be up my mask won't
gonadal be locked you know and so then
we say okay well first of all let's look
at the evidence there's no lock on the
door you can't get locked in you have
used the last 12 times yet to put your
gas mask on you did it in the right
number of seconds and and lastly the gas
we're using is not you know it's
unpleasant like you're icing but it
won't kill you and so applying evidence
to unreasoning fear is much more
effective than just screaming at
somebody we shoot down a little bit more
on that on that set example so there's
two people you need to teach her there's
the recruit and then there's the drill
sergeant for lack of it so I fan movies
and then the drill sergeants
the ones in the movies are basically
going to shout at you is there a
situation where a you taught them not to
shout and beat that this person can ask
for this specialty recruit can ask the
special treatment a way that isn't
personally embarrassing and humiliating
no but what we do have now is
essentially every drill sergeant goes
through the master resilience training
program after graduating from drill
sergeant school because everybody
recognizes that the old thing you saw in
the movies was really not very effective
and so they're pulled aside in some
private place where they can have a know
some often you'll people are perfectly
willing to have this conversation in
front of their platoon you know they're
obviously unwilling to go through it's
all there you're at the top of the 40
foot tower and you're afraid to let go
and come down and there's no shouting
well there's no screaming you might have
to shout so they can hear you there's no
berating i think is perhaps a better way
okay a kind ler gentler it is a little
bigger and gentler but it's more
effective